let's tune into that fam again Alabama I
know you've been there in the chat you
were just collecting and hoarding all
the questions for us do you have another
one I sure do this one comes from Sarah
what do we do when we have too many hell
yeses at the same time oh yes we have
finite resources but
infinite
desires I totally get this there are so
many things that I've wanted to do with
the minimalists that in isolation feel
like a hell yes right but when you pan
out and you realize well I don't I'd
have to focus all of my time attention
energy skills talent and money to
creating these things so in isolation
there a yes but what makes something a
hell yes is when you take it out of
isolation it can only be a hell yes in
the context of your broader life
this series we're working on right now
it's uh this YouTube series called
fragments it's a video essay series we
just talked about a moment ago and Danny
and I are working on it like in order to
work on that I had to say no to a bunch
of other things that may be more
compelling financially they may be more
compelling in various ways things that
I'd like to say yes to
individually but what makes the fragment
series a hell yes is I'm willing to say
no to every everything else so I can say
yes to that that's right hell yes is
tricky because there are a lot of things
that can feel like a hell yes at the
untested phase of ideation oh I want to
write a children's book oh man that just
sounds so exciting but it's the actual
writing part that might make you say oh
okay the real thing is way more specific
and constrained than the theoretical
idea maybe this is not a hell yes or how
about this one something pragmatic in
every day hey man we we should go to the
movie sometimes that feels like a hell
yes in theory yeah let's go to the movie
Sometimes call me tonight and see if I
want to go call me Saturday to see if I
want to go oh it turns out that anytime
we get specific about going on a given
day at a given time it turns out it's
just happens to not be a hell yes stand
okay so maybe what's hell yes in theory
isn't a priority and this is where we've
got to bring in priority with passion
hell yes isn't just about what makes you
feel excited in the moment when you
think about the idea but it's also what
are you willing to prioritize and so in
some cases where it seems like we've got
20 hell yeses that's only because none
of them are really hell
yeses yes because what happens here when
we say yes to this one thing we don't
realize the other things we're saying no
to and I remember when we first started
the minimalist I said yes to everything
because everything seemed like a great
opportunity at a time it was some small
blogger wanted to do some interview it
was a yes for a different reason because
oh you know what I haven't really done
any interviews about this so whether or
not anyone reads it or sees it I'm
saying yes to this because they would
they would get something out of it and
I'm going to get something out of it
what I'm going to get is putting in the
Reps putting in the rounds getting good
at doing these interviews so when
something consequential actually shows
up when the Today's Show calls or CBS
this morning or night line calls now all
of a sudden it's like oh yeah that's a
hell yes because I said yes to all these
other little things but eventually you
get to a point where you have so many
yeses in front of you that it is
irresponsible to say yes you have to say
no until you get that hell yes in front
of you and if you don't you end up
saying no to your hell yeses
accidentally because you said yes to all
these other things that seem
entertaining Danny I think you were
talking about this this morning actually
you're like I'm thinking about you
compared ice baths to running and both
of those things in an abstract sense
they sound like oh it'd be really great
for me to uh I'm going to go out for
this long 20 mile run because he's
training for a marathon right now and it
feels good to say next Thursday I'm
going to go out for this 20 mile run but
when Thursday shows up now all of a
sudden what happens Danny is like oh I
feel the resistance and I think the same
thing is true with the ice bath that I
do every morning I feel the resistance
but right now I think about taking the
ice bath tomorrow it sounds great but
here's the question and I think you
Illustrated you at least highlighted it
for a moment TK here's the
question would I say yes to this today
and if the answer is no then don't say
yes to it six months from now a month
from now or a year from now say no to it
tomorrow unless you would say hell yes
to it
today yeah and and and treat things like
those Choose Your Own Adventure novels
or it's like there's no right adventure
to choose it's just you choose one and
sometimes life doesn't say hey here is a
mathematical formula that can show you
which passion is a greater priority to
you part of being a human being means
taking a chance on our curiosity and
Trust ing the magic of how our path
unfolds when we're willing to have a
little faith in our ability to improvise
along the way I have two things that I
want to do I don't know which one's
going to make me more money and which
one's going to make me happier it's okay
but I trust my my path I trust my life
I'm going to toss a coin I'm going to
bet on one and it's going to work not
because it'll be predictable but because
it'll transform me into something that I
can never be today by just standing here
thinking about which one's the right one
and Sarah if you haven't done so already
check out Derek civer wonderful book
it's called hell yeah or no and I think
that'll give you some additional context
about what are we saying yes to why am I
saying yes to all of these things how
can I say no to those things so I can
say yes to those hell yeses that are in
front of me I hope you enjoy that
highlight if You' like to see another
one check out this video right here if
you like to see that full episode check
out this video here or if you'd like to
dive deep into the full private podcast
subscribe via the patreon link in the
description your support on patreon is
what allows us to keep this podcast 100%
advertisement free